SARAH WELDON: Good
morning, everyone.
Welcome to MLAI
100, Actionable AI
Insights Using Translation
and Natural Language.
I'm sure everybody has
had a night of good sleep,
and coming here refreshed
on the last day.
So welcome, and we're
excited to get you started.
Today for our speakers
we have myself.
I'm Sarah Weldon, the Product
Manager for Cloud Translation
API and AutoML Translation.
Followed by Olga
Beregovaya who is
one of our customers, VP of
Language Services, WeLocalize.
And then one of my
peers, Sudheera Vanguri,
Product Manager for Natural
Language Processing, API, as
well as AutoML Natural
Language Processing and DUAI,
which is one of our new products
that we launched this week.
And finally Kiran Kaza
will close us out,
the Head of Mobile
Engineering with DocuSign
who will walk us through
some really great use
cases for natural language
processing with mobile apps.
Here's an overview
of the session today.
We'll keep working through
stuff because we have
a pretty jam packed morning.
I'll be starting us off
with our language insights.
You might be familiar already
today with AutoML Translation
that we launched last year, as
well as Translation API, which
has been around for a bit of
a longer time with some very
powerful 100 language
pairs of translations
that can be used with
mobile applications helping
to go to new markets
between Japan and India,
or Spain and Portugal.
This API helps you seamlessly
translate between content
to help your users connect.
Additionally, Natural
Language can do things
like entity extraction.
It can do sentiment analysis.
And even beyond that.
So as I said earlier, we
launched AutoML Translation
last year, and it
allows customers
to bring their own training
data to further customize
and improve our existing
translation capabilities
to tailor fit to their
particular use cases,
and to strengthen it in
their language pairs.
We have new updates
that we've continued
to invest in our
AutoML platform,
including investments
in our base platform
that will help our customers by
reducing their overall training
costs, to make improvements
in the training efficiency
that we've found in
observable reduction,
and 20% to 40% reduction in
training time, which reduces
the overall training costs.
Additionally, AutoML
Translation now
supports HIPAA compliance, which
is great news for our health
care customers.
Translation API, as I said,
has been around for a while,
and today is a really
important juncture
where we're continuing
to advance the features
and capabilities to better serve
our localization providers,
as well as streamline
capabilities
for our developers.
So today we are
announcing new updates
with a set of features that
will help customers have greater
control over their brand
data, as well as be
able to do longer running
operations for translations
asynchronously.
So this allows you
to do more file
translation-type capabilities.
And then finally,
Translation API V3,
which is we're going to
be coming out ahead of V2,
will be introducing
model selection.
So for the first
time with one API,
you'll be able to choose whether
you want to use the best model
fit for your needs.
So you could use our
general NMT model.
You can use your existing
AutoML custom models
that you have built. Or you can
use the model of your choice
with our capabilities.
We'll be starting off today
with batch translations.
So today, you can now
use your GCS bucket,
take files that you have
in a source language,
say, English, put that
in your GCS bucket,
and text or HTML is accepted.
And then place a request
to your Translation API
with your Google project
and request the translation
to be returned to you in
file format in a GCS bucket
with several-- we can
do multiple languages.
And you can use a mix of our
pre-trained translation models,
or an AutoML model that you
custom trained yourself.
This allows you to do a single
Translation API request that
refers to GCS bucket,
and in single call,
you will be able to do multiple
files, multiple languages,
multiple models all
in a single request.
And then glossary, which we'll
talk more in our customer
session with
WeLocalize, you will
be able to have greater
granular control over things
like your brand IP,
or location names,
or other specific
terminology that
is tailored to your company.
If you have a small
set of training data,
additionally, that you
want to start with,
but it is really important
to you, so for specific terms
you're able to use this with
either our pre-trained models
or our custom models to
be able to have control
to ensure that the
translations are delivering
at the right quality, and also
to reduce the amount of work
that your human translators
need to do after the translation
and machine translation
has come out.
All of these
features, because they
are all part of the
same Translation API V3,
will work together.
So you can use
glossary with batch,
you can use batch
with custom models,
you can use glossary with custom
models all through one API.
And WeLocalize will come up and
talk about how this adds value
to their customers as an
LSP by combining glossary
with these various cases
to reduce the overall needs
for their company.
So this is Olga Beregovaya,
VP of language services
with WeLocalize.
OLGA BEREGOVAYA: So I represent
one of the world's largest
LSPs.
As you can see, we
are fourth in the US,
and seventh in the world.
This is a little bit about us.
So we have over
1,500 employees--
and damn, I should have
brought my glasses.
OK, I didn't.
But I don't need
to read, basically.
Oh yeah, I have it all here.
Well, I can't see
that that well.
I left my--
But anyways, I mean, I
know my company inside out.
We're pretty big.
And what's important, we
serve a variety of domains.
And this is where
the glossary feature
that I'm going to talk about
comes in extremely handy.
Because our
customers, some of us
come with huge training corpora
of million plus translation
units, which allows us to
avail of AutoML model, which
I'm going to talk about.
But some of us will come with
just glossary or not even that.
So we need to harvest
domain glossary from, say,
internet, or open
source, or translation,
automation association.
So there was just a tiny
glossary at our disposal,
but the customer would
demand domain adaptation,
or we would work with customers,
subject matter experts
and build a glossary.
So customization is necessary,
and I will explain why
in a minute.
So here is the scale
of our operation.
And what I'm going
to talk about,
it's like opinion portal
for restaurants today
or it's like an automotive
company where all they
care about is with, say, is
it a crane or is it whatever.
So here is WeLocalize for
you, and this is what we do.
And you can see it's
life sciences today,
it's legal tomorrow,
and it's God
knows what day after tomorrow.
And these are the
services that we
provide from digital services
and interpretation, which
is probably a growing
field, training data
for machine learning.
So here we are, and this is
what we're going to talk about,
glossary case study
where we're going
to compare Google
pre-trained models, which
would be generic models, versus
Google pre-trained models
with customized glossary.
And then we're going to
compare AutoML models, which
are trained with
customer corpora
with a glossary put on
top of custom models.
And what the glossary
would do for us
is allow us to add even
more granularity on top
of terminology selection.
And then the languages, why
did we pick the languages?
As you can see, we
have a romance group,
then we have Germanic group,
then we have a Slavic group,
and then we have some
more representation
from the Romans
group of languages,
and then we have
an Asian language.
So we basically see what
the glossary feature,
what the dictionary feature does
for different language groups.
So obviously, we'll see highly
morphological languages,
slightly less
and then we see Asian
languages, which basically
operate on the idiograph level.
So how did we rank
the languages?
How did we evaluate them?
We have highly
trained evaluators
that used evaluation for
adequacy and fluency,
and then engine
ranking, AB ranking
based on error typology.
And that's a methodology some
industry standard methodology
combined with the localized
proprietary methodology.
And then we see better
quality and user satisfaction,
which in our case we're
a services providers,
so it translates
into higher quality,
and subsequently,
higher productivity,
which in turn translates
for pricing, time to market,
and better final output
quality for our customers.
So why customize a glossary?
Have a look.
Driver, driver, and driver.
We provide services, as I
said, we provide services
across a variety of domains.
So do we want driver two
when we provide services
to a hardware, software company?
Obviously not.
Have a look.
Pin, pin, pin.
Again, services across
a variety of domains.
Do you want pin one,
pin two, and pin three,
depending on the domain?
Obviously not.
Now, let's have a
look at the models.
See how-- and that's
Google pre-train model
with a dictionary
injected on top of it.
As you can see, dictionary
pre-trained models with a--
pre-trained model
without a dictionary
consistently loses
to pre-trained model
with a dictionary.
And you can see that's
consistent across all
the languages that were ranked.
Maybe the difference
is not as drastic,
but the difference is
consistently there.
And same goes for
the engine ranking
across the variety
of error types,
especially with the
terminology when
it comes to both in domain
terminology and customer
specific terminology.
And when we poll our
translators, what bothers them
most as they perform
post-editing process,
terminology is usually
the biggest culprit,
because when the
translator translates,
and what the customers
are most sensitive to,
that's usually terminology.
Higher number when it comes
to engine ranking for Google
pre-trained models.
As you can see,
higher number means
which translator is better
with the following error types.
Again, you can see
that the higher
number means fewer errors.
And again, you see a pretty
consistent picture here.
Accuracy and fluency results,
now you look at Google AutoML.
Google AutoML rated for
accuracy and fluency.
And again, you see the
same consistent picture.
So engine ranking
for Google AutoML,
again, you see the same results.
Whenever the
dictionary is injected,
the translator preference
and the ranking
is, again, in favor
of dictionary.
So the summary and next steps.
We obviously can see that the
gains in accuracy and fluency
for all the languages
using the glossary feature
comes on top, both on Google
with pre-trained models
and on Google with AutoML.
So the dictionary injection,
what does it do in reality?
Whenever you inject
the dictionary,
you refine the
terminology, whether you
are using Google
pre-trained models
or whether you are
using Google AutoML,
and whether you are able
to refine the terminology.
When you use Google AutoML, yes,
you train with customer data.
But still the training data
can have some ambiguity.
Some translation segments
can translate in certain way,
some translation segments
can translate differently.
But the dictionary
feature is very
specific around the terminology.
Now, a couple of things of
what we're doing at WeLocalize.
We still make sure that
we [? cleanse ?] for named
entities, such as proper
names, such as product names,
such as geographical names,
such as, I don't know,
location names.
And then we also
make sure that we're
very consistent around
specifying do not translate,
and we remove all
terminology ambiguity.
So it's also very important how
you massage your glossaries,
how you massage your
dictionaries before you
feed them into the Google
dictionary feature.
And then next thing, we never
just utilize AutoML or Google
pre-trained models.
They're just by
themselves in isolation.
We always make
sure that they are
a part of the API integration
in our translation management
system, because both Google
pre-trained models and Google
AutoML are integrated in our
end to end global content
direct delivery workflow.
And that's basically the
essence of our partnership.
So once all these
features are in place,
and once we've expanded the
integration to other languages,
we do see tremendous benefits.
Again, as I said, we work
across a variety of domains,
and our customers come to
us from so many domains
and with such
variety in how much
data they bring to
the table that we do
see great benefits
in this feature.
And on that note, I
pass the microphone
to Sudheera who's the
Product Manager for NLP.
And she'll continue.
SUDHEERA VANGURI:
Thank you, Olga.
Hi, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm Sudheera, and I
lead NLP at Google
for products such as Cloud
Natural Language, AutoML
Natural Language, and our
document or standing AI
solution we just
announced this week.
Today I'll be
covering an overview
as part of this session for two
of our products, Cloud Natural
Language and AutoML
Natural Language.
Our Cloud Natural Language
API, which is currently in GA,
supports various key features.
Our content classification APIs
enable you to classify content
into over 700
different categories--
think sports, lifestyle,
entertainment,
music, so on and so forth.
Our sentiment
analysis API enables
you to detect the
prevailing emotion
of a writer within a text
passage, both in conversations,
as well as documents.
And we do this at a sentence
level, at an entity level,
and a document level sentiment.
Our entity extraction
APIs enable
you to identify
commonly found entities
on the web, such as Google's
an organization or beverage is
a consumer good,
so on and so forth.
Our syntax analysis APIs enable
you to identify parts of speech
and break down a sentence
into its granular tokens.
Today we have two new updates on
our Cloud Natural Language API.
We've added more entities
for invoice specific entity
analysis and extraction.
And we've added new languages
to our Cloud National language
API.
First, our invoice
specific entities.
Think about entities
commonly found on receipts,
such as dates, addresses, phone
numbers, companies, prices,
and numerical values.
We have now loaded this all
in to a pre-trained entity
analysis API available to you as
part of Cloud Natural Language.
This will enable you to
automatically convert
an unstructured invoice or a
receipt into structured data
within a matter of seconds
using our pre-trained Google
model that has been
trained on Google data.
The good part is that
these addresses are already
validated for you
by Google Maps,
so you can easily
type the address
that you've detected,
for instance,
on this receipt, to the Places
API on Google Maps to identify.
Let's say you've
found a receipt that
has an address of a restaurant.
You can identify the lat-long
values of that restaurant
and get the metadata
on that restaurant,
or store all of this
in structured format
into your own database.
Invoice processing becomes
very easy in combination
with our OCR APIs.
You can easily convert all
of this unstructured data
into structured data using
our entity extraction APIs.
Second, our new languages.
You may already know that our
Natural Language APIs support
multiple languages.
Today we're adding support
for Russian and Japanese
for some of our more popular
APIs, like our entity analysis
API, our entity sentiment API,
and our syntax analysis APIs.
Let me pause here for
a bit before moving on
to AutoML Natural Language.
A quick show of hands.
How many of you have trained a
custom natural language model?
Quite a few.
How many of you have deployed
a natural language model
in production?
A smaller percentage.
Well, I hope that by
the end of this session
you'd be as excited as I am
to deploy a natural language
model in production
within a matter of hours
using our AutoML Natural
Language product.
Last year we announced
AutoML Natural Language,
a product that enabled
citizen data scientists
to train custom natural language
models, specifically, a content
classification model without
writing a single line of code,
using a simple and
easy to use interface.
And the model quality
is inherently high,
without any hyper parameter
tuning involved or any machine
learning expertise involved.
Today we're announcing several
new updates to our AutoML
Natural Language product.
So we are now HIPAA compliant,
so our medical customers,
our health care
customers can easily
support content classification,
entity extraction,
as well as sentiment analysis
on any medical document format.
We're also adding support.
In addition to our content
classification models,
we're packing in two
more custom models
into AutoML Natural Language.
You can now train a
custom entity extraction
model using AutoML Natural
Language, as well as a custom
sentiment analysis model.
All you need to do is come
into AutoML Natural Language
with some amount
of labeled data.
This labeled data could
be custom classes, custom
entities, or tags you would like
to identify on your documents,
or customs sentiment scores
tuned to your own business
or domain.
We enable you to
quickly, in a four step
process, that import your
training data, click on Train.
Train your own custom model
for about three to four hours.
And you get an out-of-the-box
custom classification model,
custom entity extraction model,
custom sentiment model that can
start predicting, so that
you can get insights that are
relevant and tuned to your
business, your own domain.
Let me deep dive a little
bit into our AutoML Sentiment
Analysis feature that
we've just announced today.
AutoML Sentiment enables you
to do domain-specific sentiment
analysis on your documents
or conversations.
Why is domain-specific
sentiment analysis important?
One of our customers,
Avalon Solutions,
has used AutoML
Sentiment Analysis
to build an empathetic chatbot.
Now, this is a
stress coaching app
for workplaces that
enables the chatbot
to respond with empathy
when it detects stress
within a conversation.
So if an employee were
to type into a chatbot,
it's really hard right now,
or I'm really stressed work,
or my day is going
really bad today.
The chatbot responds,
sorry to hear that.
And this is all working on
top of AutoML Sentiment.
So the Avalon Solutions chatbot
has AutoML entity extraction--
sorry--
AutoML Sentiment
Analysis built-in
to detect stress
within the conversation
so that it can start responding
and starting to create a more
engaging customer experience
with the Sentiment Analysis
feature.
This can improve the
quality [? operations, ?]
and we've seen that the AutoML
Sentiment model performs
with a higher accuracy
or higher precision
than a generic sentiment model
to detect emotion or sentiment
scores that are very
tuned to a conversation
or a certain business domain.
It does not really apply just
to a conversational use case.
Think about documents
specific sentiment scores
that may be relevant
to detect sentiment
on a financial statement
or earnings statements.
Volumes of earnings statements
are generated every quarter,
so we can use AutoML
Sentiment models
to predict analyst sentiment
towards those earning
statements.
We can use AutoML Sentiment
to detect the market sentiment
towards news articles,
or on a lighter note,
you can also use
AutoML Sentiment--
pun unintended-- to do sentiment
analysis on musical lyrics.
Let's say there is a
tweet called Delta,
I was waiting on the
tarmac for two hours.
Now, this is a totally
made up tweet--
sorry, Delta.
You may be familiar with
our sentiment analysis API.
Now, if we were to type this
into our sentiment analysis
API, as you can see, the
sentiment score is neutral.
Our sentiment
analysis API doesn't
know that waiting on the runway
for two hours is a bad thing.
Let's try to apply
AutoML sentiment
analysis to make this better.
Now, I found a data
set on CrowdFlower
that is specific
to airline tweets.
Multiple airlines are listed,
and this is a custom sentiment
score from zero to two, zero
being the most negative,
and two being the most positive.
So I've taken this data set and
pointed a link to a GPS bucket
with that data set on
AutoML Natural Language.
All I need to do is specify that
this is the customer sentiment
scale that I'm going to be
supplying AutoML Natural
Language, zero to two.
Quickly verify that my label's
in order, and click on Train.
Now within a matter
of three hours,
I get a customer sentiment
model, no code involved.
All I need to do is
check the precision
and recall, look at
a confusion matrix,
check if my sentiment model is
confused on all of these three
labels, and go back tune
my training data if needed.
Look at the false
positives and negatives.
Now, as you can see, our
AutoML Sentiment model,
our airline sentiment
model, knows that more leg
room is definitely good.
And losing luggage
is not that fun.
And waiting on the tarmac is
probably not that fun either.
So that's sentiment
analysis for you.
Our third AutoML Natural
Language model, customer entity
extraction, enables
you to identify
domain-specific entities
within your document.
Now, why would
domain-specific entities
be relevant to your business?
Imagine you have a
document or you're
an energy company with oil
and gas reservoir parameters
that you would like to extract
from within your documents.
Our regular entity
analysis API would not be--
is tuned mostly for
detecting web-based entities,
so it may not perform really
well in detecting, let's say,
the density, the
pressure, viscosity values
of a certain reservoir
in the Gulf of Mexico.
Let's say you have
doctor's patient notes
that you are trying
to analyze and you
would like to extract
specific symptoms or diseases
from within that patient note.
You could be-- and well, the
invoice example that we just
saw, we are able to predict,
well, prices, numbers, phone
numbers, so on and so forth.
But they may be specific dates,
like billing dates, supplier
dates, so on.
And so there is variations of
entities within those documents
that you would like to tune
and tag on those documents.
AutoML entity extraction
enables you to do just that
without any code involved.
Again, all you'd have to do
is provide some examples,
and we ask for at least 10
mentions of each entity type--
100 for a good model--
so that you can start building
a custom entity extraction
API that performs really
well for your own business
specific use cases, or your
own domain-specific documents.
Let's launch into a quick demo.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hey.
Today we're going to talk about
how to build a custom entity
extraction model with Google
Cloud AutoML Natural Language.
If you've played with the
Natural Language API before,
you might have seen that it
can extract common entities
from text, like the fact that
Google is an organization,
or that iPhone is
a consumer good.
But what if you wanted to tag
more domain-specific entities,
like types of diseases, or
the specialized terminology
you might find in legal
documents or patents?
For that we'll use AutoML to
train and build a custom entity
extraction model.
First we'll need
a label data set.
Today we'll build a model that
analyzes patents from Google's
public patent data set.
Using Google Vision's OCR
API, we extracted the text
from a set of PDFs of patents.
Here we've stored
that data in a JSON L
file, which is the data
type that AutoML Natural
Language expects.
And we've manually
tagged within that text
the character offsets
of the custom entities
we want to extract.
AutoML Natural Language expects
to read our JSON L files
from a Google Cloud bucket.
In addition to our
JSON L data, we'll
make a CSV file that tells
it where in Google Cloud
we've stored our data.
Here we specify which
data file should
be used for
training, validation,
and testing of our model.
If you don't break your data
set into these three files,
AutoML Natural Language will
do it for you automatically.
Now let's upload our data.
Here in the AutoML natural
language interface,
we'll create a new data set.
To import the data, we give
AutoML Natural Language the CSV
file we made, and then we wait.
Importing data can take a
couple of minutes to finish,
but you'll get an
email when it's done.
Once our data is imported, we
can view individual examples
to make sure they were
labeled correctly.
We can check where in the
text different custom entities
were annotated.
We can also annotate
a new entity right
here from within a tool.
Notice that we can also
tell how many examples we've
got for each label.
We can begin training a
model by navigating over
to the Train tab and
clicking Start Training.
Training a model can
take up to three hours.
Behind the scenes, AutoML will
do a neural architecture search
to find the best model it can.
So now's a good time
to take a coffee break.
You'll get an email when the
model's finished training.
When training is finished, we'll
be able to see our model here
in the Train tab.
We can see how well it
did by clicking here
to see full evaluation.
Here in the evaluate
panel, we can
see the performance of our
model on different labels.
The metrics we'll want to look
at are precision and recall.
Precision tells us of
the snips the model
labeled applicant, how many
were really applicants.
Recall tells us of all the real
applicants in our data set,
what percent were accurately
recognized by the model.
We can also scroll down to
see where the model correctly
labeled applicant-- these
are the true positives--
and where it accidentally
mislabeled text as applicant,
or false positives.
In the Test and Use tab,
we can start actually
using our model
hosted by Google.
To do that, we first have
to deploy our model, which
could take a few minutes.
Next, we can try to extract
custom entities on a new text
snippet.
There we go.
Here are the custom
entities we extracted.
That's all for now.
Have fun modeling.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
That's exciting.
Well, that was the demo.
With that I would love
to invite Kiran Kaza,
Director of Engineering
at DocuSign,
who has used AutoML Natural
Language for auto tagging
documents.
Let's find out what he's done.
KIRAN KAZA: Thank you.
Thanks, Sudheera.
All right.
Hello, everyone.
Good morning.
My name is Kiran.
I lead mobile engineering at
DocuSign and some fun key AI
machine learning initiatives.
You probably know
DocuSign today because you
used it to eSign an important
moment in your life--
maybe buying a new house
or maybe a new car.
But today, DocuSign is more
than a e-signature company.
We are an agreements
cloud company
and helping our
customers modernize
their systems of agreement.
Part of modernizing
systems of agreement,
we are focused on delivering
best-in-class products
for preparing agreements,
signing agreements, managing
agreements, and acting
on your agreements.
As we think about modernizing
systems of agreement,
we are adding intelligence
to our agreement process
to eliminate and
reduce manual actions.
That's where we partnered
with Google for auto tagging.
While I'm on DocuSign I would
love to share a quick story,
and this one I love.
So this was four
plus years ago when I
started working with DocuSign.
One of the evenings I was
going back home on Bart,
and I don't know--
for people who are
not local, Bart
is our local commuter train
from downtown back to suburbs.
So I was going
back on the train,
this gentleman walks over
to me and says, dude,
do you work at DocuSign.
And yeah, I do.
He's like, I love DocuSign.
I just bought a home
and I signed everything.
It was so easy.
And if you talk to many of
my colleagues at DocuSign,
they will share similar--
I love DocuSign stories.
And it is such a
great honor to work
for a product that meaningfully
touches people's life, and such
a huge impact, as they are
dealing with important moments
and issues of their life.
So that's us.
That's who we are at DocuSign.
Now, let me talk about the
problem we're trying to solve.
Today, when our
customers send documents
out for signing using
our web or mobile app,
they had to manually place tags.
So what is tagging?
What does this word tag mean?
Tag is a DocuSign term used
for identifying form input
fields where customers
can input data, and also
draw the signatures.
So let's take an example.
There's a NDA document that
I sent out for signing.
You'd expect your
customer to input
the name, the date they
signed the document,
the signature itself.
All these different input
fields are for those tags.
And as we can see on
the animated GIF there,
manual tagging can be done.
We do it today.
But it does delay time to
value, and it is error prone.
Our goal is to
seamlessly identify
tags based on different
tag types in categories,
and place them on the document
so that user doesn't have
to place a tag, move it around,
make sure it's properly x
and y coordinated, and
it is matching the label
for which the tag belongs to.
So when we thought about solving
this problem, and why Kiran,
why did mobile pick
up this problem?
Imagine tagging or placing
tags on this form factor.
It is not fun.
We definitely wanted
to make this process--
for my domain, it
was a big problem.
And I tried many things.
We tried OCR.
We tried OCR with custom code.
None of them really
worked at the scale
at which DocuSign operates.
And the different use
cases my customers had.
All the different document types
I had, none of them really,
really worked.
So the only way to do this right
was using AI machine learning.
So we partnered with Google,
and the first question
was why Google?
I think there are three key
reasons I call them out.
One, I believe Google has
the best-in-class product
for Vision deep learning
AI, and Natural Language AI.
I do think that they have
best-in-class products there.
The second key factor is AutoML
is a very powerful tool which
helps us manage our model
accuracies and performance.
And finally, partner with Google
engineering and [INAUDIBLE]
was a lot of fun.
Being an engineer myself,
I had a lot of fun
working with Google team,
partnering with them, because
on a scale of solution, solving
this problem could not be done,
in the [? first written ?]
by ourselves.
We needed some help there.
So essentially we had
three different models,
and I'm going to
walk you through
the different architecture, how
we solved this problem pretty
soon.
But we have three
different models.
First, we are using
Vision OCR, we
are using AutoML Vision
object detection model,
and AutoML Natural Language
entity extraction models.
And all these three
different models
we trained with thousands
and thousands of documents,
and hundreds and
thousands of tags.
That's the only way we
could get the accuracies we
are seeing right now.
Before I actually talk about
the architecture, let me demo
and show you guys how
this really works.
Can you switch to demo, please.
So here I have my mobile device,
and the first thing I'm doing
is launching our DocuSign app.
As you can see, there's a
Create button for somebody
to create a document,
as I mentioned
before, the use
case is somebody's
trying to create a document.
So I create a document,
I load a document first,
and from my local file
directory, I'll pick a NDA.
The document is loaded.
In typical DocuSign
world, any NDA
would require two different
people agreeing to an NDA.
So we call them signers.
In this case, I have two
different test users.
I'll use Tamara,
my first signer.
And the recipient here, in
this case, I'll use Martin.
So these are my
two different test
users I'm using for signing.
The next thing I want to
do is load the document
and send it out for signing.
Now, as you can see,
in literally instantly,
without user having to
do any interaction, then
tag document, this tag, all
the fields I'm zooming in,
all the fields are tagged.
If you go look at the
bottom of the document,
both the recipients
will need to sign a tag.
Ready to go.
And all I need to
do is long press
and assign few fields to
Martin, and this document
is ready to be sent.
So if you can
imagine, the entire
process of tagging very--
I had to manually place tags,
make sure they're aligned,
all that is gone.
So some of you might
be thinking, Kiran,
that's a simple use case.
India had like 10 fields, dude.
Come on, really?
Is it that hard?
So let's take a more
complex use case.
I have another example here.
So I'm using a US passport form.
So I don't know how many
of you, but I recently
renewed our passport form.
They are at least 350 fields
on this document, if not more.
So I'm going to take a US
passport form, load it.
For the sake of
using a user, I'm
going to continue using Tamara.
And now I kick-off tagging.
And you can see, now
this is instantaneous.
Then tag document is tagged.
The date, the check boxes.
Now let's go through
the rest of the fields.
There it goes, guys.
Look at the beauty of this.
All these fields are tagged,
the signature tag is tagged,
the whole document is
tagged and ready to be sent.
Back to the slides, please.
So as simple as the demo was,
as quick as the demo was,
that's the beauty
of auto tagging.
That's the beauty of
AI machine learning.
You can really
simplify and eliminate
manual processes that otherwise
would have taken a lot of time
for normal users to do.
So I'm going to now explain how
we actually solve this problem.
I'm going to start at
three different levels.
At the document level,
which is simple business--
for a business owner,
what does it mean?
And then I'm going to talk
about architecture and how
the models really work.
At the core document level,
let's take an example
I'm loading a W-9 form.
I want to use this for tagging.
The first thing we do is extract
text, the OCR aspect of, hey,
what are the different text
components in this document?
The next thing I do is
identify bounding boxes.
For people who have done
machine learning on Vision,
they know bounding boxes is
the technical machine learning
term for tags.
And sorry to throw
another term on you,
but they're called
as bounding boxes.
Once we get those results
back from both of them,
we process them to
form fill analysis
where we apply more contextual
meaning of the bounding box
with the document.
For example, if
there's a sign here
and there's a tag next to
it, it is a signature tag.
It's not a text field.
So applying that concept is
the form fill analysis we do.
And then eventually, as you see
on the screenshot, by the way,
that's coming out
from our auto tagging
machine learning algorithms.
So there's a completely tagged
W-9 form there to be used.
I'm going to go a level deeper,
talk about how it's actually
architected.
A user makes a call
to a GCP endpoint.
We internally call
an App Engine.
We need App Engine because
I'm not making a straight call
to single model.
We actually have multiple
models who do different work.
So we want to do some
orchestration there,
and App Engine helps us
do that orchestration.
The first call we make
is a simultaneous call
to OCR Vision model, and AutoML
Vision object detection model.
Then the idea of
those two models
is extracting text,
identifying the bounding boxes.
The results that we get back
we feed back to the App Engine.
App Engine then
forwards that request
to AutoML Natural
Language entity extraction
model, which does form field
analysis and processing.
And those results get
fed back to App Engine
where we do clean up.
Why we need to do clean is a
lot of times tags will overlap,
if there are two tags
very close to each other.
So there is a lot
of noise, and you
want to eliminate
some of those noise.
And so some of that logic is
built-in our App Engine site.
It returns us then
back to Cloud endpoint,
and finally we give the
results back to the users.
So it looks a little complicated
because for the scale DocuSign
operates, we operate at billions
and billions of documents
and transactions.
We had to use multiple models
to come back and provide
the proper results that
you saw in the demo.
Now let's talk about how do
the models really operate.
So now this is how document flow
works, how the architecture.
Well, the next step is
understanding how models work.
Again, this is a
very simplistic view.
Internally, the models
are more complex, but just
for sake of understanding.
Let's say the Vision
object detection,
at your right at the very
top, identified something
as a text tag.
So the category you're
trying to find, hey,
I looked at the document, it
looks like it's a text tag.
And the OCR model found,
hey, this text tag
is between words saying,
sign in favor of.
OK?
Now, when we mark the
results, you see sign,
there's a text tab, and
there's sign in favor of.
So this tag actually
is a signature tag.
So Natural Language
entity extraction
classifies bounding
boxes and represents them
in the context of document text.
And now the result is you can
see the category of the tag
is signature.
So that's the beauty of Natural
Language entity extraction
models.
So well, implementation of
this is a lot more complicated.
It does take more time.
But I'm going to take a
step back and talk about
what does it mean for
users point of view?
What does it mean
for the business?
We actually solve
three problems.
At the very foundation, we
are making agreement processes
faster.
We are eliminating manual steps.
It becomes easier
for customers to use.
Secondly, once you apply
machine learning logic,
it's less error prone.
It is a lot more user friendly.
There's more at option,
so it's more reliable.
And like any other
machine learning project,
it is self-learning
and intelligent.
As these models are used more,
as these models are seeing more
data and get trained
more, they just
keep getting better over time.
So in business view, we
are making a process fast,
reliable, and intelligent.
Finally, that's pretty much
how DocuSign solved our problem
with the help of Google.
And I'm going to pass
it back to Sudheera
to walk us through closing.
[APPLAUSE]
SUDHEERA VANGURI:
Thank you, Kiran.
Since launch of AutoML
Natural Language,
we have seen applications
across multiple industries
from real estate, to news,
media, travel, music, energy,
voice of customer
analytics, and we
are extremely
humbled by the amount
of traction we are seeing.
Thousands of AutoML
Natural Language models
have been built to
classify security documents
with GDPR compliance,
HR files, again,
to track GDPR compliance, or
to classify certain document,
downloads, sensitive
document downloads.
We've seen various applications
in news editorial processes.
We think that we are able to
apply Natural Language to solve
various business specific use
cases across multiple domains.
And we are constantly
actually excited,
and sometimes surprised by some
of the innovative applications
of our technologies,
our NLP technologies,
towards solving
real business needs.
We'd love to get more
feedback from you
as you start to try using
AutoML Natural Language.
Please feel free
to reach out to us.
This is where you can find more
information about our products,
our Natural Language products,
our AutoML Natural Language
products, and our
translate products.
We also have a session on
more advanced use cases,
and a solution called Document
Understanding AI, a deep dive
of that will be available
at 1 o'clock today
in one of my other sessions.
Please feel free to attend that.
Your feedback is always welcome.
Thank you so much
for your time today.
I'll stick around for more
questions right after.
[MUSIC PLAYING]